9th grade is always awkward.
Pimples, braces, and “the talk”.
Hey everyone, Julia here for DNews
Health class get super awkward in high school.
Where they talk about sex.
But A 2011 Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention (CDC) survey indicates that more
than 47 percent of all high school students
say they’ve had sex.
So sex ed isn’t going away anytime soon.
In fact, it’s actually a good thing.
One study published in the Journal of Adolescent
Health found that students who have any kind
of sex ed wait longer to have sex, and when
they do, they are more likely to use contraception.
So people want it.
One poll by NPR, the Kaiser Family Foundation,
and Harvard's Kennedy School of Government
found that 93 percent of Americans agree that
sex education should be taught in schools.
But there’s a debate on what kind of sex
ed is best.
Currently federal funding goes towards two
main types of programs.
The vast majority of federal funding for sex
ed programs, go towards what is called abstinence
only programs.
These programs teach that the only safe sex
is not having it and emphasize that waiting
till marriage is the best.
When they do mention contraception, it’s
typically to show how often it fails.
This type grew in popularity throughout the
early 2000s.
Funding for abstinence-only programs increased
from $9 million in 1997 to $176 million in
2007.
But more recently, in 2010, funding was also
put towards what’s called “comprehensive”
sex ed.
This can also emphasize waiting to have sex,
but it also talks about how to keep yourself
safe.
LIke how to use a condom, what birth control
options are out there.
That kind of thing.
Who gets what, is really left up to the states.
And there it get super confusing.
Only 22 mandate any kind of sex education,
18 states and the District of Columbia require
that information on contraception be provided.
37 states require that information on abstinence
be provided.
And even fewer—13—require that instruction
be medically accurate.
So which works better?
How do we define better?
A successful sex ed program might be defined
as one that lowers pregnancy and STI rates.
So a look at the literature on abstinence
only programs finds some misunderstandings.
One study from researchers at the University
of Washington found that “abstinence”
meant different things to adults than it meant
to the students.
The intent of the abstinence programs was
to set up a dichotomy with any kind of sexual
activity on one hand and total abstinence
on the other.
For kids, the lines got a little blurrier.
The researchers said that students were on
an escalator.
“the first step is abstinence.
Then as they begin to be aware of sex, there
are other steps and choices to be made that
eventually lead to having intercourse.”
So it’s not surprising that one review by
the US Department of Health and Human Services
found that none of the individual abstinence
programs they reviewed had statistically significant
impacts on the rate of sexual abstinence.
So basically teens were having sex whether
or not they were taught abstinence.
At the same time, teens are having sex, they
aren’t using protection.
One study by Columbia University's Mailman
School of Public Health found that from 2003-2007
contraception use declined.
The researchers think it might be the result
of abstinence only programs which don’t
mention contraception unless it’s to talk
about how often it fails.
So teens have sex, without protection, and
with sex sometimes comes serious consequences.
One study in PLOS One found a link between
abstinence-only programs and teen pregnancy.
Basically, states that emphasized abstinence
only policies had a higher teen pregnancy
rate.
The researchers concluded that comprehensive
sex and/or STI education that includes abstinence
as the best way to go was correlated with
the lowest teen pregnancy rates.
And a lot of other developed nations provide
comprehensive sex ed and have low rates of
teen pregnancy.
To learn more about how other countries teach
sex to their teenagers, check out this great
video from TestTube.
Alright so the question is, what was your
sex ed class like?
Was it all “if you have sex, you will get
chlamydia and die”.?
I had horrible sex-ed.
We had someone come in a tell us that when
you have sex, oxytocin is released in a woman’s
brain that binds her to her partner.
Which yeah oxytocin is called the love hormone
for a reason.. but then the teacher went on
to say that oxytocin is like tape, the more
you use it, the less sticky it gets.
so basically the more people you have sex
with, the less you’ll get attached to them.
Which is just… well bullshit.
Anyways tell us your story down in the comments
below.
Hit those like and subscribe buttons so you
don’t miss a single episode of DNews.